[Music]  we've been talking a lot lately about  how President Obama he's been struggling  a bit to find a new campaign slogan for  2012 something is memorable as change  you can believe in  well Mitt Romney is also trying out new  campaign slogans now that he is the  nominee and he's having mixed results  take a look I'm offering a real choice a  new beginning  we believe in ourselves our greatest  days are ahead I'm proud to announce it  could be worse  I'm sorry it's my turn you had yours now  it's my turn I'm not a person of core  values I don't have a core that's what I  might the headline you read what you  said let Detroit go bankrupt you do  exactly what Ron Paul said I love cars I  know I mean I do totally in love with  cars  [Applause]  I forgot about who let the dogs out sure  oh I didn't I listen to it every day  before the show why that's why I seem so  charged